the original tip drawing is from Paul
Davies and then yeah it's one of these
idea about this membrane theory and then
like also like when the tension is so
much in one of the membrane you know it
kind of appears fear this is I mean it
come back to this idea of a cosmic phone
and what it happened before the origin
of the universe and from what is made
and then go back to really kind of a
Quantic scale and kind of other
questions you know one of the things
which I always kind of get is Paris
about this idea of you know multiple
universes and I mean and then what it
comes also the idea about his membrane
theory or m-theory does it mean you know
is always then you can go back to the
work is I will really now in Italian
Giardino the same theory Casey before
can annoy it was a one of kind of the
books also who can over start with this
idea of the multiplicity amendment
possible parallel universes
it means you never know what you do an
action here my rapper could in some
other universe in this possible theory
and this way also what it happened when
you enter you know you are suspended
quite high like almost 20 meter from the
ground and there are kind of three
different membranes does it mean when
you walk in one of the membrane in the
top one you squeeze the membrane under
is kind of a lasagna is something that
you really kind of buy your own weight
entering today to the part of the
installation you you know at the same
time generate form and space because if
if you don't enter with your own weight
you know all the three layers are
squeezed one to each other this mean is
yourself in your own body which kind of
shape the space around you and also
deform the space of the other people
which are walking does it mean you know
it's like let's say due to maybe the
butterfly effect right and you don't
like a butterfly spinning some wings
here might produce a tornado somewhere
this mean is somehow hopefully we'll
sensible eyes this kind of you know
entangled relationship that we have
maybe with a planet earth and between us
when you ask me people what is made as
culture well I would say a seven
thousand cubic meters of air when you
enter the piece I mean one of the things
which first happens when you open one
door in the second or you know a big
flow of air we count does it mean what
happened is really kind of your hair
maybe it kind of turn around and you can
start to move and then you know what
when it happened when you open it
sometimes people will forget the tooth
or open does it mean there is a huge
volume of air which is going out does it
mean you kind of first feel that inside
the room there is something which is air
at another pressure which normally we
breathe and then I see so that the other
thing you will see the people up there
somehow they will start to fall because
then you will understand oh my god you
know as long as I lived two doors open
the people up there is what is thanks to
the air that they are kind of floating
above us you mean there is this kind of
start already like a kind of a
codependency about like the people which
ended in lower layer and the layers on
the top and this is what it somehow the
first maybe relationship that you can
establish for a very two different parts
of the piece somehow in both of them
cannot complete it they stabilize the
work because you know there is one
moment where where people are on you
know on this layer and then there are
other two layers which I never had done
it and never have done in this dimension
it's been spied you and I don't know
it's kind of for me I take it like a
really kind of an experiment piece
because I hope so everything we were but
also what it means to work in itself in
the lecture does it mean it's not only
like a the movement of the people
upstairs which each moving or people
affect which are kind of inhabit the
piece itself but also the people which
entering the lower part listening is the
same breath of air that you have each of
us breathe allowed somehow to breathe
the piece itself I don't know there is
this story for example in
both of I think so he's a cosmos from
Carl Sagan what is this story that a
nephew's original story from standing at
lamb and then there are people on earth
trying to see if there is life in
another planet and they build up like a
telescope first day or year or whenever
of this dimension they look through it
and they say well there is nothing going
on that the next year the built it will
be bigger
they look again trying to see if there
is life or so and then nothing and then
they keep doing it bigger and bigger and
then there's a moment that the telescope
is so huge you can say like maybe the
square right kilo meter telescope
developing in Chile but you know let's
imagine that it's bigger and bigger they
tell us that there's a moment that the
others one see first the telescope on
earth that we through the telescope see
the other one I mean there is always
this kind of inverse maybe relationship
and also maybe my attitude towards doing
the things you know you try to do
something in certain direction but at
the end you discover that what you do
helps to see something else that you did
not expect it is all about this open
source and a way of collaborate to do
something you know in somehow and in you
know go back to vernacular architecture
but you know there is some kind of an
embed acknowledging between people and
society which somehow you know have to
be triggered by something to understand
it really we can / it's necessary to
collaborate it's necessary to
communicate and it's necessary to
understand how much the movement that I
do affect the movement of the other one
Proc Semyon approximately is the use of
the space that make each culture in
relationship with their other you know
what I mean very very simple say oh you
go to the subway in Paris and you have
the feeling of smelling and maybe the
distance is different but if then he
tried to really measure it and then say
like how the space is used in
relationship we don't know how and the
knowledge that you have and the behavior
of you know it's something that you
somehow you can balance also how people
behave in relation to each other is not
only let's say in this case the volume
in the way that we were thinking
I like the idea that in the future we
might be able to also build the cloud
cities and city which my simulate clouds
and then also how is the way also how we
communicate travel and you know there is
something today which is going on in a
level of the atmosphere which is they're
trying to build this kind of high
altitude platform this amine it will not
only be you know this kind of
possibility of Klaus it is not only the
possibility of physical inhabit but also
you know if you think about it satellite
or how Internet is built upon and then
you know is like and where in which area
today are communicated you know and it's
a very cheap alternative of building
satellites is much more easy to deploy
it cause much less this mean you know
they you know and what this bring also
to people living in another floating
city which is the planet Earth today
this I mean it's also like a kind of a
something which you could inhabit in a
one way or another but yeah but I'm very
enthusiastic to think like that will be
in the kind of the first prototype of
affairs molecular affairs module of
offers and kind of a layer of a membrane
you can later you can add it to another
one and then you can add it another one
and then slowly it could form a kind of
a possibility of of applying city